one of the things about glow is that
you're capturing this period in 80's and
I would think the locations are crucial
because you can't just shoot anywhere
because the 80s was such a specific time
visually I don't know how you guys are
able to do it you do it very well but
you always make it look when you're
walking around in locations like it's
the 80s yeah it's tricky well then this
season it all takes place in Vegas and
what's left of the 80s in Vegas is gone
there's nothing there so they had to
find a hotel
yeah and they found one I don't know
where locations people find these places
they found a hotel out by the Anaheim
Airport did you even know there was an
airport at night there there's a hotel
there that they kind of reconfigured
into you know they made it into a Vegas
hotel put them our key up created the
lobby there but it's not a nice place
Conan the hotel is not nice no how many
people are staying at the classy hotel
by the Anaheim Airport not many not many
and you get there and it's one of those
hotels where they tell you like we have
some permanent residents never a good
sign if a hotel has people that won't
leave not great not a great indicator
and there was actually this moment where
wasn't a moment it was an email because
we were shooting out there for a few
days and they said that we were free to
stay there and this is mostly women in
this cast and there was this caveat I
think it's the correct usage of his word
that said there is a guy that kind of
walks around the halls and lives at the
hotel he's a bit weird he calls himself
Hollywood and he's obsessed with movie
sets so that's happening there was no
attempt by the hotel or their staff to
detain this man or ask him to no he said
there's generally people at the hotel
security but this is a you know Alison
Brie's gonna stay there with Hollywood
creeping around the halls and there was
one scene where I'm shooting would
breathe in a hot tub you know in the in
the in the courtyard of the hotel and
out of nowhere there's someone just
starts yelling from from a room just
start screaming it was inaudible and we
were like that must be Hollywood that
night
this is Hollywood's moment that's
classic Hollywood classic creepy stalker
guy who's uh he didn't make the cut by
the way you won't hear him in that fight
you still got paid we have a clip here
and I believe this is with you and
Alison Brie and I think you're shooting
in the hotel that you're talking about
no no one's gonna know you could have
just said yeah whoa holy [ __ ] really
it's okay she look at it for me at the
lost and found and you're owned it I
mean I don't need to know that now I'm
thinking about how it got there
you look nice too hmm thank you we'll
have a drink before we go up fine
yeah well just come in and watch me ever
drink then come on got you on opening
night card you did no I thought about it
for a few seconds would have been good
asking you like it thank you you're very
good at it you're very good actor I'm
excited to be doing it and it's fun to
work with people like her she's genius
you know antastic uh yeah I feel like I
think I I mean I'm not like I'm doing
pretty well with the acting but I'd like
to take some more risks you know what I
mean like I don't think I'm gonna put on
30 pounds or learn an accent but it'd be
maybe just some more maybe some
different fashion choices right like an
eye patches yeah I thought it's great